come on something big is going down
tomorrow I need you to remember these
three numbers hq2 now that doesn't make
sense to you right now but it will soon
let me explain now you know no me I'm no
alarmist but we are at war a war for the
future of civilization the future of
civilization and I made a short list of
the enemies we need to focus on most of
these I can handle on my own but
sometimes an enemy is so big so
dangerous that I need your help and Who
am I talking about Amazon Chuck play the
scary thing we made Amazon has a Pollack
awfully they've been allowed to set up
with Communist China Ibiza is a total
eugenicist centralizers what will amazon
gobble up next
with world domination try it yourself he
wants to destroy America
they're never going to stop we didn't
even add that music to that it just came
up on its own Alex has blown this whole
thing wide open for us and it's not just
an oligopoly it's a whole diplodocus of
evil
now you may think you know this enemy
but you don't Amazon isn't just some
virtual store it's a 485 billion dollar
empire that has America by the balls and
by the balls I mean by the wallets by
the wallet I mean by your balls over the
last 15 years Amazon stock price has
gone up 8,000 percent that's math talk
for hide your kids hide your wife this
company Amazon for the most successful
companies in the history of the stock
market how do they do it
murder specifically book murder Amazon
founded in 1994 with the goal of
becoming Earth's biggest bookstore they
used their massive online inventory to
undercut all the mom-and-pop shops as
well as the book stores run by the
childless
I saw it happen it's true you can look
it up google it but don't trust Google
coz they're following you
I saw it happen in my small hometown in
southwestern Michigan when I was a kid
the bookstore was as popular as the soda
fountain the roller rink or the lead
paint Emporium then I amazon hit the
internet and my quaint American paradise
shriveled up like my neighbor mrs.
Davison it's a terrible story lead
poisoning it's terrible
according to the mainstream town coroner
but that was just the beginning
books were a man amazon's gateway
product do you see where I'm going do
you get it yet I got a picture come on
come on
Amazon the Concord retail then started
devouring other industries it's not just
a store anymore it's also a media
platform a hardware manufacturer a
utility an ad tech company a grocery
delivery service and a television studio
a studio so evil it makes comedies
without any laughs
transparents really if you're crying in
a show or don't understand it guess what
it's a drama and this bloated behemoth
continues to consume everything in its
path
so far they've acquired or invested in
at least a hundred and twenty eight
other companies that we know of
it could be 228 or 328 how easy you just
add 200 it's simple this year
they snatched up this crunchy chain of
probiotic pushers Whole Foods have you
ever been to Whole Foods more like whole
paycheck I made that joke and anyone who
says otherwise is a liar but Jordan I
said right now to myself pretending that
me is you why are we talking about this
today again because of those three
numbers I said before hq2
it's code for second headquarters that's
right the Amazonian virus could be
spreading into your very own backyard if
you haven't heard yet Amazon is building
a second headquarters it's gonna be a
five billion dollar investment with
50,000 new jobs 100 different towns and
cities contending to get Amazon their
liberal billionaires aren't supposed to
set up shop wherever they want they're
supposed to stay in Seattle
a bizarre-o City where the fish are
thrown through the air and there's a
Space Needle on the ground
the deadline for submission is tomorrow
and cities across America are begging
the digital conquerors to march into
their homes and the pandering is
pathetic look the City of Tucson sent
them a giant cactus the mayor of Kansas
City wrote a thousand five-star product
reviews get up off your knees Kansas
City wipe yourself off and decide what
goddamn state you're in look disgusting
if you've seen one of these groveling
pitches you've seen them all
hey Alexa where should amazon locate HQ
- hmm in Frisco Texas Alexa where is the
best place for Amazon to locate its
second world headquarters Danbury
Connecticut Alexa where is the most
interesting company in the world I'm
gonna locate obviously Washington DC
Alexa you three faced liar so do seem
desperate politicians with false
promises it makes me sick Amazon has
fooled you small town America you're
begging for the wolf to come inside and
eat your grandmother and then offering
him tax cuts to do it I know you need
you need someone to stand up and face
this wolf down mayors cover your ears
this could get ugly here Amazon CEO Jeff
Bezos I'm Jordan Klepper from beautiful
Kalamazoo Michigan where the tax breaks
flow like beer just like the adorable 37
micro breweries downtown Kalamazoo is a
great place to own property I bought
what some might say is too much property
there
I've got six acres of functioning
warehouse on top of 14 acres of
non-functioning radon ditch it's a great
town with great people and I'm not the
only one who thinks so
Alexa where's the real best place for
Amazon HQ to Kalamazoo Thank You Alexa
also please reorder my foot cream I'm
watching you Amazon